do you mind talking about your your
first state would your first state quit
sounds quite dramatic yeah we just mad
and we were gonna work on a show so that
was like normally out of the question
and where we found ourselves in a house
that she was renovating and we were just
having a great time we didn't want to
leave each other we're just having a
good night I hear you and we were in
this in this you know this houses no
there's nothing in the house it's empty
and I had to break in because it had
been locked up she didn't key or
anything so we found our way around and
next thing I said well where's you know
what's upstairs it's just the bedrooms
of the bedrooms are upstairs good we
were sitting there's a fireplace there
and we started you know dreaming about
things and one thing led to another and
we were having a good time and the next
thing I know there's a flashlight beam
on on on us and it was really
disconcerting you know it was like the
local police but not police they're like
they're like guards you know and clearly
they'd been there for a little while
[Laughter]
[Applause]
not every Santa can be as successful as
you and of course with any one meets
Santa they have the picture taken that's
just what you do and they're all those
pictures we've all seen them out on on
the world wide web of people we decide
this is the traditional children who
find they don't enjoy the experience as
much as they thought they would
that's their thing I did that one time
because we were we wanted to get our
kids that why it was little and he was
not there and I said well weird you know
I'll do it where's the costume I gotta
get this going here this is what he came
down for so I actually did it for an
hour and then other kids came but I
learned something about it and it's very
true and it was verified when I was
working on this show kids are fascinated
with Santa Claus but they're very
intimidated by him because they're very
well when they're far away from you
they'll stare at you and they'll they'll
really look you over but the closer they
get especially if they're coming from
the line and they get the AAA all of a
sudden then they never look at you they
look down and there they Santa Clauses
is a little is a little scary for them
and and I wanted to carry that into this
into this movie and I think that's true
some children like that are frightened
of Santa Claus but sometimes I feel
Santa Claus should be frightened of the
children
all Santa's got a big smile on his face
there's so much wrong with that picture
[Laughter]
children who aren't a scared of Santa as
I think they should be here's three
children oblivious to you know because
if there are Givens in in these pictures
you know Santa is a man he's a little
overweight there's a child of ZAP this
one breaks a lot of those rules
it's a ginger woman but no child
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you